تشير التقارير الى ان تشخيص اضطراب نقص
الانتباه مع فرط النشاط اصبح اكثر شيوعا
وايضا ارتفاع في عدد وصفات الادويه
المستخدمه لعلاجه وفقا لمؤسسه اي دي اتش
دي الخيريه في بريطانيا يعاني نحو مليونير
في المملكه المتحده من هذه الحاله وهذا
يشكل ما نسبته 3 الى 4% من السكان
البالغين تشير المؤسسه الى زياده قدرها
400 في المئه في عدد الاشخاص البالغين
الذين يسعون الى التشخيص منذ عام 2020 في
الولايات المتحده وبين عامي 2016 و2020
بقيت نسبه السكان الذين حصلوا على وصفه
طبيه لعقار منشط هذه النسبه كانت ثابته
نسبيا لكن شهد عام 2021 زياده ملحوظه حيث
قفزت الوصفات الطبيه باكثر من 10 % في
غالبيه الفئات العمريه لتصل النسبه الى
اثنين ونصف في المئه من البالغين
الامريكيين الذين قد يكونوا يعانون من
اضطراب فرط الحركه ونقص الانتباه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات